ideas are crap because I get 10,000
emails a week from people that want me
to invest their companies and they tell
me that they have the greatest idea of
all time everybody in here has an idea
the amount of times somebody comes up to
me goes oh I had the uber idea before it
happened great what do you want a cookie
like like like like ideas are completely
completely completely worthless unless
you execute against those ideas and you
can sit here and tell me what your
purpose is but unless you go and execute
against it it's no different than
something like an idea which is
completely meaningless without
fundamental execution it's the hardest
thing about being a CEO and trying to
get an organization to change culture
change slowly it's hard and you know
being a CEO is hard you know especially
when it's your business you know if I'm
a CEO in corporate America I'm a hell of
a lot more interested because even if
you fail you still get enormous cash
bonuses on your way out so that's
interesting that I like being an
entrepreneur of an independent company
like myself is if I stink we go out of
business and you don't get the bonuses
and you don't get the accolades and you
know my business my life is predicated
on headaches you know 20 minutes before
I got here I was in my hotel room here
it's so beautiful here I don't know who
saw the ocean it's gorgeous everyone's
have a good time there's candy for days
in the backroom and what am i doing I
mean I'm in my room dealing with four
major headaches problem at the problem
at the problem plus I'm an HR driven CEO
so I like to get into the muck so you
know meaning like I really fundamentally
care about their opinions on you know
I'm really the head of HR even though I
just hired a chief heart officer to
really enforce HR but you know mom-mom I
could be on a call in a couple hours
that's Susan who says hey Gary
Karen's trying to ruin me you know that
could be like 40 minutes of my day you
know oh you know what's it like to be a
CEO it's lonely you know listen it's
really fun to be able to clap up like
yeah it's the machine it's the man I
stood in front of my entire 75 person
office in LA and said look just so you
understand every
thing that is wrong with this company is
my fault all of it because I empower all
the other people that are screwing up
right so so you know how is it for me I
love it it's you know I love the action
I'm an entrepreneur it's it's my oxygen
I couldn't do anything else I've never
worked for anybody else I don't know
another gear it's my DNA but it's not
that easy like we're living through the
greatest era of fake entrepreneurship
right now in America because everybody
in their 20s is popping out and they're
the next Mark Zuckerberg we have 99% of
those companies about to go out of
business once the next financial crisis
which I hope happens soon comes so that
we can wipe out all this fake
entrepreneurship and all this bull crap
but you know but it's hard yeah I mean
you look at the universities in America
right now that have entrepreneurship at
the forefront Babson UPenn they have the
highest rate of suicide because a lot of
kids right now think that it's just so
easy to like when did this happen when
did everybody just think they can build
a million-dollar business just because
you live in America and you're 24 and
you have a hoodie there's a stunning
conversation because entrepreneurship is
very Americana it's very hot right now
but being a micro industry celebrity
it's crazy to me how much the
entrepreneur is being put on a pedestal
I'm feeling it enormous Lee and and I
think it's dangerous because I don't
think people think they can just be
LeBron James I don't think people think
they can just be Beyonce I don't think
they can think they can just be these
things yet for some reason we're in this
place right now where we think we can
just build these million-dollar
businesses and entrepreneurship is a
skill it's a talent it's like it's you
know most are born with it you could be
better at it but to be a great one and
then and then we have a crazy
conversation around income like the fact
that the bottom of the 1% earners in
this country make $400,000 a year yet
all these 20 year olds think that a
million dollars a year is like the
baseline for like maybe being in the
game
we are just completely in the outer
space right now on this conversation how
can this audience use empathy and their
daily business
I think I think empathy is the greatest
trait that I was gifted by my mother and
and I use it every day I think it makes
me a great salesperson I think way too
many organizations don't deploy empathy
ever and and most of all not on their
end consumer they most of you think way
too much inside of a bubble and you get
into a room and you whiteboard in things
that are in your best interest but not
in the end consumers best interest so
empathy is completely left depth at the
garbage before you walk into the door
and for me I try to run my organization
and my offerings and when I sold wine
and when I sell books and when I sell
client services and whatever I do for
the rest of my life
my goal is always how do I deploy 51
percent of the value of this transaction
to the other party and I use empathy I
try to understand why this organization
needs to take a step back and understand
why nobody in America knows what a
credit union is that would be the first
step to a lot more money made for
everybody in this room not your
emotional - why it's not happening not
that it should be happening not
succumbing to its happening but
understanding why it's happening and
then that would help and the way to do
that is to deploy empathy and understand
what's happening in people's day and day
our lives that isn't allowing us to
penetrate them with a messaging that
describes what we do for a living
why does snapchat exist communication is
the foundation of how human beings act
and communication has gone from drawing
stuff inside of caves to standing on top
of mountains and making smoke signals go
read go read what people wrote about the
invention of the telephone it was going
to ruin us we made it right snapchat
exists because it was an ideation and an
evolution of communication within the
mobile device which is the single most
important thing in our society guys how
many people here within every 24 hours
including when they're sleeping are
always within arm's reach of their
telephone raise your hands high
look at this not 14-year old girl and
the important point is 10 years ago 50%
of the audience in a sworn they'll never
get a cell phone
right and so there's six year old dudes
in here who texted a poop emoji last
night I mean look at this lovely lady
got to technology devices a phone and I
bet she's gaining years old there are a
lot of CEOs that run companies that know
that they're not going to be there in 24
36 months that know the math behind
their bonuses which are completely based
on P&L profit and to be successful in
six years from today you need to deploy
money to have the infrastructure and the
capabilities for six years from today
the problem is you're going to be on
your yacht or playing golf and so you
don't personally get benefited for the
investment in the company so you as a
human and I don't blame you humans are
flawed do behavior that's in your best
interest as Rick and Sally not in the
best interest of X Y Z credit union
that's real like that's real they would
be by the way that's why so much doesn't
happen just we thank you thank you thank
you guys thank you for having me side
[Applause]
[Music]